مدينه بخموت في الشرق الاوكراني مسرح
للتواصل القصف المدفعي رغم بدء سريان وقف
اطلاق نار احادي اعلنت روسيا
اوكرانيه في المدينه قالت ان الهدنه
استفزاز روسي لن يساعد المدنيين الذين
يقصفون ليلا ونهارا
واعلانات عن سقوط قتلى يوميا تقريبا من
جهته اكد الجيش الروسي احترامه الهدنه
لكنه اتهم القوه الاوكرانيه بمواصله قصف
المدن والمواقع الروسيه
السلطات المحليه عن 14 قديفه مدفعيه
وثلاثه هجمات روسيه بين مظل المدنيون طوال
اليوم في الاغبياء نائب رئيس اداره
الرئاسه الاوكرانيه تحدث عن ضربتين
روسيتين على كرامات بالشرق الاوكراني
استهدفت امامنا سكنيا ولم تسفر عن ضحايا
وفي وقت سابق اعلن عن قصف روسي على خير
جنوبا من جهتها نقلت وكاله انباء روسيه عن
السلطات الانفصاليه في الشرق اوكرانيا
حديثها عن قصف على مواقع
الجيش الاوكراني قبل بدء سريان وقف اطلاق
النار الخميس
اكد الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ان
بلاده منفتحه على حوار جاد مع اوكرانيا
شرط ان تقبل كياب الوقائع الجديده على
الارض في اشاره الى اعلان موسكو في ايلول
سبتمبر ضم اربع مناطق اوكرانيه تسيطر
عليها جزئيا او بالكامل بينما يسر
الرئيسكي على انسحاب كامل للقوات الروسيه
من بلده بما يشمل شبه جزيره القرم قبل اي
حوار مع موسكو